is your witness out there is a witness
out there he's down the hall judge
all right bringing the jury in
alright be seated everyone morning
ladies and gentlemen of the jury hope
everyone had a good evening we're going
to continue with the trial
we're going to resume with the testimony
of detective bailly officer can you
bring in detective bailey please
all right somebody's got to mute
your computer please
it's not just muted it's the sound has
to be on completely
muted and the sound has to be turned off
all right because of the break will we
swear detective bailey please place your
left hand on the bible raise your right
hand
do you swing the presence of almighty
god that the testimony to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes please state your nameless by
your last name for the record detective
brian bailey
t-a-i-l-e-y
thank you
thank you detective have a seat please
keep your voice up nice and loud again
if you don't understand the question
please indicate that on off council
rephrase
we'll resume the testimony the direct
testimony of detective bailly go ahead
mr shellhorn
thank you robert
good morning detective good morning
i think yesterday uh we concluded your
testimony talking about uh some articles
of clothing that you recovered from the
rear of the farmhouse yes uh you had
identified two articles of clothing that
you recovered near the stairway
a red and black shirt s182 and a yellow
sweatshirt s183 yes did you collect any
other clothing from outside the
farmhouse area in the yard yes
and what was that
a red nike polo shirt
and uh judge
i'd like permission to display a photo
it's s216
it has been moved into evidence
very well what's your number
216.
detective i know we were just here
yesterday but you could just reorient
the jury to 216 and what the vantage
point of this photo is
that's the rear of the residence
just off the driveway to the back a
little bit and that is the white trailer
where mr barristone was when i arrived
on scene
and i think you indicated yesterday that
he was in that area receiving attention
from some medical folks that's correct
are you aware that certain articles of
clothing or items of potential
evidentiary value were left in the area
when mr barisson was removed from the
scene yes
and i'm going to direct your attention
next to s250 in evidence
what is s250 a picture of
that is a picture of the clothing um
located near mr barrison
and uh
was the condition of the clothing in
that area the same as the condition of
the clothing that you recovered in the
back of the farmhouse yes and can you
tell the jury what that was
that is uh the condition of clothing was
saturated with soaking wet um
and it was the the red shirt and the
shoes
and i'm going to direct your attention i
think it's on the desk in front of you
there to what s 186 what is s186 it's
the red nike polo shirt
and uh how can you tell that that's the
redneck polo shirt it's in the bag
that i collected it in
just at this point i'd like to move
s-186 into evidence and show it to you
any objection
186
red nike shirt
be accepted into evidence it may be
displayed to the jurors go ahead
detective
all right detective you removed the uh
shirt from the bag does that appear to
be in the same or substantially the same
condition although it's dry now as when
you recovered it on august 7 2019. yes
and uh if you could judge with your
permission if the detective could walk
it down in front of the jury into the
gallery showing
the front on the first pass and then the
back on the second pass
certainly go ahead detect it
i guess for purposes of the record it
would be the outside of the shirt
because it's cut on the first pass and
that will be the inside of the shirt on
the second pass
thank you detective you can put that
back into the bag
yes
judge i just handed forward to detect
the daily s-179
s-180 and s-181
those were items of evidence recovered
at the scene
i'll ask that they be admitted at this
time so the detective can shut them
right s 179 180 181
will be admitted into evidence
i believe 181 is already in evidence i
believe that's true
179 and 180 will be admitted
detective bailey at some point while you
were in the area of the scene i know
that you had indicated that you marked
certain items of evidence with placards
correct
and i'm going to draw your attention
first
to s207
we're just pulling it up
i believe you testified to this photo
yesterday correct
again just uh for purposes of the record
can you reorient the jury to the angle
or the vantage point that s 207 is from
this is a mid-range photograph located
in the driveway of a placard number two
that is covering a
potential piece of evidence in this case
a shell casing
and is that placard uh the larger
placard covering the smaller placard
yes um the director attention to s 234
what is s 234 a picture of
that's a picture of a shell casing and
which placard is next to that shell
casing a number one and do you see that
in this photo yes where is it
top right of the photo
was there any significance to the
numbers of the placards that you placed
down on the various pieces of edits no
they were just used as reference points
for photographs
now the shell casing that we're looking
at uh in s234
did you collect that shell casing yes
and do you see it in front of you marked
as s 179 yes if you would
please just remove that and show it to
the jury
this might be tough to open
now detective you uh testified that
that's a shell casing correct based on
your training education experience what
is a shell casing shell casing is
when it's fully intact it's a bullet
when it's discharged from a weapon a
firearm it's now a discharge shell
casing
so i'm sure we'll have more testimony
about ballistics later on in the trial
but uh are you saying that when a bullet
is shot out of a gun
the projectile comes from the front of
the barrel while this is ejected from
the ejector port
and you located that in the area of the
driveway behind the farmhouse yes
all right thank you
next i'll direct your attention uh to s
and 204
and what is s 204 a picture of uh it's a
mid-range photograph of another placard
two um
in the back patio area the driveway and
i believe you testified to this photo as
well yesterday
that you took this photo
just after it started raining correct
direct your attention to s-236
what is s-236 a picture of it's a
picture of the shell casing that is
located underneath the
fire debris can with the evidence marker
on top of it
and can you remind the jury why you went
back and put that can over the top of
the shell casing with the weather that
we were getting and the amount of rain
that we got in such a little bit of time
i decided to use fire debris cans to
kind of
dig them around the shell casings so we
wouldn't lose any potential evidence
was that fire debris can uh used or was
it new brand new
next i'll uh show you two s237
what is s237 a picture of uh spent shell
casing
and uh would this be the same shell
casing that you just indicated you had
originally marked with marker number two
yes
can you describe
obviously you know we're looking at the
picture but can you describe where that
shell casing was found and what the
condition was
uh the shell casing was found in the
rear of the driveway
just off to the to the left um in the
grass area
but being with the water it was slowly
getting submerged in water so that's why
we preserved it and covered it
and you have s 180 in front of you
correct what is s180 it is that shell
casing
did you collect that shell casing yes
did you put it into that envelope yes
and if you could just remove it from the
envelope and show it to the jury
thank you detective
after you collected the shell casings as
well as all the evidence you collected
where did you take it
uh it was secured into the command post
um that was located on scene and when we
were clear from the scene those pieces
of evidence were then transported back
to the crime lab and secured in the
evidence room
and at some point are you aware whether
certain evidence were submitted either
within your agency or to other agencies
for further examination yes
do you know if those shell casings were
ultimately given to someone from your
agency for examination yes they were
and do you know who that was yes who was
that uh forensics examiner bill stitt
now i'm going to show you next uh s 239
[Music]
what is s239 a picture of uh it's a
mid-range of the rear of the driveway
slowly coming into the back of the
residence with the evidence placard
number one marking a
magazine
and again was there any significance to
these placards no
uh what do we see in the top right of
the
[Music]
picture
in between the i guess the
the truck and the uh
those white items
what's the yellow item in the top right
there
those are the evidence placards that
were marking the shell casings in the
driveway and would that have been shell
casing the first one that you showed
s179
yes all right so with respect to the
item that we're looking at in the
foreground of this picture i'm going to
direct your attention to s240
what is s240 a picture of a magazine
and what is a magazine a magazine is
what contains the cartridges for a
handgun
is this a close-up photo of the magazine
that you located in that grassy area yes
were there any bullets located inside of
this magazine no
i believe that's already been moved into
evidence as well you have s 181 in front
of you yes is s181 the magazine that you
recovered from that grassy area yes
and how do you know that
it's in the bag that i put it in is your
handwriting on the back
yes
all right detective when you were
finished
searching the area of the
farmhouse and processing that area did
you search and process any other areas
of the property
yes then proceeded up to the dressage
area
process the clubhouse in the office
all right detective billy i'm showing
you what's been marked as s 301 in
evidence what is s 301 a picture of uh
that's an overall the entrance working
our way into the office
so this would be coming into the office
from where the clubhouse
and i'm going to show you what's been
marked as s302
what is s302 a picture of that's after
we entered and photographing our way
back towards where we came from
with these photographs taken before
you've conducted your search correct
what is on the right hand side of that
picture s302 oh safe
did you search that safe yes
did you recover a number of items from
within the office area yes and did those
items include certain electronic devices
and uh various paperwork yes were those
all uh marked as evidence and then
logged into evidence yes in the same
method that you described earlier yes
all right i'm gonna ask you some
questions about uh searching the safe
um i'm gonna show you s 303
in evidence
what is s303 a picture of oh that's an
overall of the safe
and was the safe uh
in that condition meaning the door was
closed when you got into the room yes
was it unlocked
i believe so
and you were able to open the door and
get into it yes
all right next i'll show you s304
what is that 304 a picture of uh that's
an overall photograph of the inside of
the content
and is that a fair and accurate picture
of the contents of the safe before you
conducted any search yes meaning that
that's how the items all appeared when
you first opened the safe yes
judge if i could have permission to
approach
certainly
[Music]
uh
all right detective did you uh collect a
number of items that were located in
that safe yes
and if you could just describe for the
jury
what some of the items that we can see
in the picture as 304r
uh there's a pink and black gun case
um
there's a and where is that that's on
the located on the top shelf
and what's next to that pink and black
orange uh plink and black gun case there
is a dummy magazine located directly to
the right of that pink and black case
can you tell the jury what a dummy
magazine is dummy magazine you can't put
any rounds in any bullets in and that
would go into a weapon to keep the
weapon safe
what would be uh those items that are
located to the back left on the top
shelf behind the pink and black gun case
those are various different types of
ammunition
and did you uh were you there when that
ammunition was catalogued yes
moving down to the next shelf below that
on the on the left-hand side of the
safe what are those items on the
left-hand side those are rifles
and were you there when those items were
collected by the washington township
police
i wasn't physically in the room but
during that night yes
um to the right of that on that second
shelf down in the very center of the
picture what is that uh item that looks
black and copper
that is a box of nine millimeter rounds
and what is behind those that box of
nine millimeter rounds there is two
revolvers and one semi-automatic angle
all right detective i had handed up a
number of items just now uh s 306 is one
of the items excuse me s190 is one of
the items that i have handed
and i'm going to show you
a picture s306
what is s306 a picture of that's a box
containing nine millimeter rounds and
did you uh
photograph that as it was when you
opened the safe yes
can you describe the condition of that
box and the state of that box when you
open the safe
box was partially opened uh
what we're looking at in the the back of
the photo or the middle of the photo the
back of the box was slightly torn um and
it was open until approximately the
fourth row of bullets
and i think um
to your left there there is a pointer we
tried charging last night i don't know
if it will work on this picture but if
you could just point out
to the jury
can i stand
yes yes
can you see it
yeah
it's uh so the box was was partially
open ripped up at the top here um if you
can see me circling on it trying to do
my best
but um it was also open until
approximately the the fourth row of
bullets like midway
and you did you collect that box of
bullets yes and do you see that box in
front of you or do you see a package uh
an item of evidence s 190 yes what is
s19 s190 is the
box of ammunition nine millimeter round
the same ammunition that we're looking
at
yes could you open that please
and detective if i could ask hold on
that's not in evidence yet are you
moving it into evidence i'm sorry judge
i thought when i handed them forward i
asked him to be in evidence i apologize
i'm not sure you gave the numbers
judge i had handed forward s-190
okay
all right s190s and evidence go ahead
detective judge if i could just at the
same time ask for s 191
s202
s199
s 200 and s 201
any objection to those items
mr blencus
those items are in evidence you may uh
stand up and show the item to the jurors
detective so i could ask that you could
open that box uh
carefully
and pull out the
tray with the the bullets in it and then
judge if i could ask that that could be
walked around to show the jury the uh
condition of approximately how far open
it was at the time the detective
searched the scene certainly go ahead
detective
oh
uh
thank you detective billy if you can put
that back into the envelope
[Music]
detective we're pulling up next s305
what is that a picture of it's a picture
of a pink and black
uh gun case and located directly to the
right of that is the dummy magazine
now what was the and you
took this photograph before you
collected those items yes uh what was
the condition or state of the black and
pink
uh
gun case it was it was open
and and how does it open and close with
a zipper
uh do you see in front of you
s-191
yes
and if i could ask that that has been
moved into evidence if i could ask you
to open that to show the journey
and is that currently open or closed
open could you uh
open it for the jury and
show the inside
detective billy what is the blue uh
plastic item that's inside the gun case
these are typically used to
stick through the barrel
or up through the the chamber to make
the weapon safe and it's basically a
flag so
somebody else would know the weapon is
safe as well
and that was inside of the gun case when
you collect it correct was there any
other item or items inside the gun case
when you collected it no
thank you
now you indicated in s-305 that there
was also an orange dummy magazine next
to the case correct
i'm going to direct your attention to
s-202
which i think you have in front of you
yes
are you aware if that item was collected
by the washington township police yes
and i'm going to ask you to open s 202
and that has been moved into evidence so
i would ask if you could
judge again if this could be walked down
and shown to the jury back in the
gallery certainly go ahead detective
detective if you could just show
one side on the first pass and then the
second side on the next pass
um
uh detective you indicated that there
were a number of other guns located uh
in the safe that's correct and were
those uh taken
into the custody of the washington
township police department that's
correct yes
did you have a chance to look at those
uh firearms before they were taken yes
were any of them loaded to your
recollection no
now you indicated that there were a
number of uh rifles or long guns on the
left-hand side correct do you recall
approximately how many uh three
and was there any ammunition for uh
those
guns
yes
and i think you indicated there was uh
some ammunition on the top left-hand
shelf
uh which is shown in s304 yes
do you remember how how many handguns
there were inside the safe there was
three
two revolvers and a semi-automatic
and i'll ask you first i think you have
those all on the
ground next to you but i'll move judge
if i can just remove some of these other
items certainly
i'll take these items out of your way
detective bailey we'll start with s199
you have s199 in front of you yes what
is that
this is a
reviver
pistol
and you uh know what caliber that was
i believe it's a 22.
uh s s 199 is that the volt 45
this is the cold45 yes i'm sorry
are you aware whether there was any 45
caliber ammunition in the state there
was not
um judge this has been moved into
evidence i like permission to show
this item to the jury
all right certainly go ahead detective
199.
yes
it may be easier
to walk it around if that's art that's
fine
detective i don't think i asked you this
question but are those guns in the same
or substantially the same condition as
when you saw them the night of august 7
2019 aside from the fact that they may
have safety mechanisms on them at this
point yes
next i'm going to draw your attention to
s200
you have that in front of you yes
what is s200
it is a semi-automatic uh handgun and do
you know what uh caliber that was i
believe this is a 380. was there any 380
caliber ammunition located in the safe
no
judge with the court's permission i'd
like to show s 200 to the jury
no objection certainly go ahead
detective
you may display it to the jurors
mm-hmm
so
detective the last item i'm going to ask
you about is
s201
do you have s201 in front of you yes
what is that 201
it is a revolver
do you know what caliber it is uh 22.
and was there any 22 22-caliber
ammunition in the state yes
judge with the court's permission i'd
like to show uh have the detective show
s 201 to the jury yes go ahead you may
step down and display it to the jury
i don't mean
detective bailey are you aware whether
those items were provided to
forensic examiner stitch in the morris
county sheriff's office yes
judge i don't have any further questions
at this time for detective daily all
right very good cross-examination
[Music]
good morning detective bailey good
morning sir
your job basically and correctly if i'm
wrong was to
secure the scene
and protect
and document
all potential evidence correct correct
now
when you got to the scene would you
agree with me that it was chaotic
yes
um
40 50 people running around doing
different things correct i'm not sure on
the number of people
how many would you estimate i'm not sure
great
so i'm going to show you 11-1
which is the crime scene log sure first
of all can you explain to the ladies and
jurors what a crime scene log is
yes the crime scene log is basically um
a log that somebody's going to be taking
to document who's coming in and out of
that scene
so we have a record of times um in and
out basically of what their friends
whether it's a police officer whether
it's emergency medical services
anybody that would be entering the scene
and were you the person in control of
that law no
can you take a look at that log
and see if that refreshes your
recollection as
to whether or not there were
approximately 40 to 50 different people
in and out of that crime scene
there's numerous people throughout
throughout the night
when you say
numerous
in excess of
50 people correct
i can count
don't don't count just does it refresh
your memory yes
i would say so okay thank you what was
your answer
approximately 40 people
thank you
what was that exhibit number
1100-1 cents
when you got to the scene
would you agree with me that it was not
secured
yes it was not secured yet it was still
an active scene
and
it was your job at that point upon your
arrival to secure the same scene and
protect all the evidence correct
i responded to this scene as a law
enforcement officer again it came across
the radio as an active shooter so i
responded as a essentially a police
officer
when i arrived on scene my role as a law
enforcement officer was still in play
being that i am crime scene-minded i did
realize that there was potential
evidence on the scene and i documented
that evidence or preserve tried to
preserve that evidence to the best of my
ability
while everything was still very chaotic
okay and and after
was no longer chaotic
you were in control of
securing all of the potential evidence
correct correct
and you indicated yesterday that in
order to do your job
you need to
talk to the officers
to find out what happened
which allows you to take certain
precautions with regards to securing
evidence correct correct
for instance you were aware that it was
uh
that a gun was used correct correct and
you were told and told a specific number
of shots potentially had been fired
correct correct i believe so correct
how many shots
were you told were fired i believe it
was a approximately three three shots
okay and uh would you agree with me that
every time
a nine million millimeter gun discharges
a bullet
a casing is discharged
correct
how many casings
did you
find and preserve
during your search
two
one's missing correct correct
now
were you aware that there was a video
camera
on the side of the house that
potentially could have captured the
entire incident yes
did you preserve that video
at that time
no based off of uh
did you processes it no
was the prosecutor's office there and
also aware that there was a video camera
that potentially could have preserved
don't don't answer that question you're
asking his knowledge of what other
people knew at the time
he said
yeah he said if the prosecutor's office
knew
that's their state of mind
rephrase the question
or join and ask another one
was the morris county prosecutor's
office or any representative
from that office
at the crime scene on that night while
you were doing your job
yes
on that day
you find both a handgun
two casings
two magazines correct correct
and those are the ones
that have been introduced into evidence
correct correct
and
um judge i don't believe that's accurate
no that's not the testimony
rephrase your question okay you found
the handgun correct correct
you
we've introduced into evidence one
magazine correct correct
and two shell casings correct correct
okay as a crime scene investigator
do those items potentially have
fingerprints
and dna on them yes were they submitted
to
a fingerprint expert and or a dna expert
at any time to your knowledge
no
now
you indicated that when you got there
and first
were able to appraise the scene
it was not raining correct correct
you indicated yesterday that
you were waiting for a search warrant
correct correct
and at some point in time
you received a search warrant correct
correct which allowed you to search
basically everything that uh you
requested on that warrant correct
correct
for instance
um
you were able to search my client's
vehicle correct correct
um
in the photographs introduced by the
prosecutor there were two other vehicles
and a trailer
in the immediate area do you recall
seeing them
yes
are you aware of the fact that they
belong to robert goodwin
i don't
did you or anyone to your knowledge
get a search warrant
to search those vehicles which were
included in your crime scene area
i did not and to my knowledge i don't
know
was robert goodwin when you arrived when
i arrived he was located in front of the
police one of the police vehicles that
was parked in the driveway
now
the prosecutors introduced uh
numerous photographs of telephones that
were on the scene correct correct
uh there's one on the uh um
it's like a round table
correct
are you aware of the fact that that's my
client's telephone i was not at the time
now
there were two other phones located on
an umbrella base
at the bottom of the stairs correct
correct and they were basically
on top of each other correct correct
and when you first got to the scene
you
photographed those items in the exact
location that they were found correct
correct and then you tried to protect
them uh because of the rain with with
plastic correct yes yes
with with regards to uh clothing
that's been introduced into evidence by
the prosecutor
uh specifically the yellow sweatshirt
and red t-shirt
with the bullet defects in them
upon seeing them
you were aware that they belonged to
the alleged victim correct yes
and
would you agree with me that
you believed it was important to
preserve them
correct yes
because certain evidential things can be
uh had from those items of clothing
correct right
now in the warrant it indicated that you
were
able
to take samples of my client's hands for
gunshot residue correct correct
now
gunshot residue
is
basically
gun powder
which is expelled both from the
weapon towards the back
which would
get on a person's hand and from the
front which potentially could get on
someone's clothing correct correct
so the gunshot residue basically goes in
both directions when a weapon is filed
correct correct now
in the warren
you were given permission
to
swap my client's hands
to make a determination if he had any
gunshot residue on his hand correct
correct
did you or anyone to your knowledge
request to do the same thing on either
lauren cataract's
or robert goodwin's hands
not to my knowledge
with regards to the clothing
were you aware that lauren cataract has
indicated that she was shot at close
distance yes
did anyone to your knowledge
conduct gunshot residue
evaluations on her clothing
to either confirm or verify
that she was shot at close range
yes and what were the results of that
hold on
did he do it
no
he can't answer that then it's hearsay i
withdraw he did do it judge i'm sorry he
did do it what hold on
say that again
this witness did it yes oh all right
then he can answer
i thought he said no that he didn't
i think i think the question was about
whether there was any swabbings of
anyone's hands no no he no that's not
what he's he he was asking the follow-up
question the results of an examination
that was done to the clothing
well he he could tell what the results
were
but he he didn't do the test
did do the test it was negative
let me see at sidebar
rephrase your question please set a
foundation for us please
sir
are you an expert with regards to
he's not qualified as an expert
no but no are you gonna you can't ask a
question if he's an expert and have him
say yes without qualifying him as an
expert to render an opinion if that's
what you want to do with him
then qualify him as an expert
you can't just ask him if he's an expert
without qualifying him and ask him his
opinion
why are you asking him if he's an expert
an expert has a specific
designation under the law
if you're going to ask him that as an
expert you have to qualify him as an
expert otherwise don't ask him if he's
an expert
i'm not sure
please
officer do you have training with
regards to uh
examination examining gunshot rescue
i have training using an infrared camera
and what results would look like
and where did you get that training
through fujifilm
and how long was that training
um to my knowledge it was an eight-hour
club eight-hour course so so basically
you've had eight hours of training
correct eight hours of training correct
and the method
that you use
uh is what in this case i used a
fujifilm xt
100 i believe camera infrared uv camera
to photograph the items with different
lens filters to produce different
results
okay and
is there more a more sophisticated
method to your knowledge
to make that determination it's my
knowledge they could be tested with a
presumptive test
and and what's a presumptive test what
do you mean by that it's a chemical
based test that you could
basically swab uh onto the item and see
if there is potential results
and would you agree that that technique
is far
more
accurate and reliable than just the uh
test that you did no
now
does the fact that the clothing was
drenched have any impact on the tests
that you did
it could have an impact on any test to
be conducted
if our tests showed that there was any
um
presence of any gsr what we would have
done is then used a presumptive test or
sent that out into the lab
and you did it with regards to uh
miss cataract's clothing correct correct
did you do it with regards to
my client's clothing no
when you say did it you're referring to
the um using the camera right yeah yes
all right you understand that's what he
was talking about yes
so
now
there was a
bullet hole in the door
by the back stairs correct correct
um
did you see where that bullet went to
can you rephrase that
did you see where that bullet went to i
saw where the bullets struck the door
and the potential flight path of that
projectile yes
and
would you agree with me that the bullet
went
through the room
and through a window
uh to the left or the right of the door
i believe that yes the flight path that
projectile did go out an exit window
did you ever find that
spent bullet
we did not find that projectile did you
look for it yes
did you use metal detectors to attempt
to find it
not that particular projectile based on
the flight path
so
you have no idea what caliber
bullet
caused that
defect in the door
and or the window and it went through
correct
and you are missing one
at least one case incorrect correct
now
those
items of clothing lauren cataract
i believe you testified there were a
entrance and an exit defect correct
that's correct which would indicate to
you that the
bullet went
through her
and her clothing correct that's correct
did you find
those bullets
no we did not
the
clubhouse area
the prosecutor has showed you
photographs of the office area correct
that's correct
and
the door to that office area is a solid
wooden door correct
i believe so yes
and when you walk into the office that's
safe that you've
testified to about is on your left
correct correct
the safe was closed but it wasn't locked
correct correct
and
i know you've testified to
that
pink and black case
and items associated with that
there were in fact other weapons in
there correct that's correct
and there was for instance a 22
revolver yes with ammunition yes
and there were numerous long guns
including a shotgun correct yes
boxes of shotgun shells that fit those
particular weapons correct right
i could just have a moment judge i think
about
sure
redirect mr shellhorn
yes john
[Music]
detective bailey are you aware whether
any metal detectors were used at the
scene uh to look for
other shell casings or projectiles no
detectors were used on the scene yes and
was that on august 7th or august 8th or
something else
uh it could have been in between on both
days based off the circumstances of the
scene i don't know what time of night or
day
but you're aware they were used they
were used correct
have you ever
do you have any experience with uh shell
casings being ejected from a bullet from
personal experience in terms of your
experience shooting at the range and
that sort of thing yes have you ever
investigated any other shooting
incidents yes
so you have practical experience with
investigating shooting incidents where
there were shell casings yes
do you have any experience with other
investigations or personal experience as
a as a police officer
with what could happen to a shell casing
or how it gets ejected from a gun yes
can you explain that to the jury
show cases get ejected from a weapon
it's not
repetition it's not the same every time
also
being a police officer shooting on the
range i have come home with showcasings
in my boots stuck to my boots so they
are
able to um get places basically
where you're stepping on them in your
clothing um where they're not going to
be
in the direct vicinity of where that
weapon was fired
now you indicated that when you got to
the scene on august 7
2019 it was not raining yet correct
how would you describe the rain that did
come down that afternoon
uh it was substantial it was very heavy
and it came very quick
and can you estimate
could you estimate approximately how
long after you got on scene that the
rain started
i would say approximately within 25 to
30 minutes of arriving on scene the rain
started
and
became very heavy at times and and
during that time were there still
individuals on the scene
either rendering medical assistance to
some of the people or trying to clean up
um
i don't believe anybody was still on
scene receiving any medical treatment at
that time
i'm going to show you again what's been
marked as
s 205.
s205 i think you had testified earlier
was a picture of one of the shell
casings in the driveway yes or the area
of one of the shell cases yes
can you see the shell casing in this
picture no why not uh it's submerged in
water
is this picture representative of other
areas on that driveway or in that yard
at the time that you
noticed the rain started yes
i think you were asked the question
about whether you were aware if there
was any sort of a camera
at the house the day that you were
processing yes
and i think you were asked if you knew
that was there and if you collected it
yes
can you explain to the jury uh what your
role was or what you knew about that
that camera based on your experience as
a crime scene officer
based on my experience as a crime scene
detective um the camera was photographed
there
we did examine that camera
on scene it was a cloud-based system so
that physical camera itself wouldn't be
storing any of our our data any of our
video um it would be going to a cloud um
for example like a ring um
ring is very common and it's a
cloud-based system so you can log into
your account
basically from a computer a phone a
tablet and you can kind of look at
what's been going on
through your cloud
and would that be something that you
and have you do you have experience with
those type of cameras based on your
experience as a crime scene investigator
yes then personal
[Music]
i think the last question i had for you
was you were asked if you had had
photographed
uh any of the defendant's clothes
that you collected or processed those
with the ir camera for gunshot residue
i was asked that question yes have you
indicated that you did process uh lauren
canorex clothing first
yes what was the reason you chose to
process those articles of clothing first
so when those articles were dried
we did we did know that um miss cameron
act did receive two gunshots um
so after those those articles of
clothing were dried throughout the
drying chamber they were then
photographed so we could see the defects
that night
during the actual crime scene
investigation we weren't able to see
those defects based on how saturated and
how wet the clothing was
so when they were taken back and dried
then they were examined for for defects
and with respect to the ir camera and
the looking for the gunshot residue is
there a reason that you chose her
articles of clothing to check first yes
we did know that those articles of
clothing after examining them with our
our eyes and a normal photography with
our normal typical crime scene camera we
noticed bullet defects so that's when we
did use the ir camera to examine those
articles of clothing with different
lights and filters and based on not
identifying any gunshot residue on those
articles of clothing did that influence
your decision not to photograph other
items jackson leading it was a little
bit leading mr shellhorn just that
rephrase your question based on your uh
examination of those articles of
clothing meaning ms canorax did that
impact your investigation
yes uh being that we had negative
results with our our ir camera um no
other clothing was then photographed
utilizing that out of our camera
judge i don't have any further questions
thank you all right
any um requests briefly uh sir
based on your experience
with
casings being
ejected from a handgun
would you agree that wherever they land
are pretty unreliable and unpredictable
as to
as to where they land yes
and
before you got there
with the number of people
could those specific casings that you've
identified and marked as pieces of
evidence could they have been disturbed
in all the chaos
which would have made those locations
unreliable yes
so based on your experience would you
agree with me
that it would be almost impossible to
make a determination as to where someone
was standing
when the weapon was fired based on
where you marked those cases being found
that's correct
nothing
all right you may step down thank you
detective thank you judge
please don't discuss the case with
anyone you may have to be recalled at
some other point in time thank you
bye call your next witness mr shellhorn
judge the state will next call mary
haskins gray
not sure if she's outside
all right have your detective check
very happy
all right i think she's here mr
shellhorn thank you officer